penelope disick brings in her 10th
birthday with a splash and leave it to
mom kourtney kardashian to document her
little girl stepping into double digits
with a party fit for a princess we're
just you know living our best lives and
yeah courtney is ready for some fun in
the sun pulling out her pink checkered
bikini and matching bucket hat to keep
up with the all pink themed bash for
peas big day
and it's not a kardashian party without
over-the-top details the decor was on
point with heart-shaped everything from
pink balloons to vegan grilled cheese
sandwiches each table decorated with
blush roses as stunning centerpieces i
love it and penelope's fam didn't miss a
beat showing the birthday girl a whole
lot of love travis barker's stepdaughter
23 year old atiana de la hoya gave an
inside look at the party posting pee
blowing out her candles at a dessert
table filled with sweets then travis's
youngest kiddo 16 year old alabama
shared a happy birthday tribute to p on
instagram that's the two at their
parents nuptials in italy
travis is a really amazing father it's
one of the reasons that i fell in love
with him he
is very very patient i think because
we've all known each other it does make
it easier to blend our families like
it's all i could ever want
it's nice to see the disick barker kids
all bonding as a family of course
penelope initially had an emotional
reaction to her mom and travis getting
engaged which we saw on season one of
the kardashians
pete how's my girl do you want to know
what my surprise was
we got
engaged mom got a ring
is that upsetting
why are you sad baby
but thankfully seems p came around and
now she's more concerned with court and
traff packing on the pda in front of her
mom
no
just one no sorry we had to what about
our certificates you gave us
what about our certificates
i'm gonna die
you guys
no fridge kissing baby okay
kravis kissing may take some getting
used to kiddos after all they're now
married and we love seeing everyone
coming together to celebrate penelope
turning 10. i love the idea of a blended
family i think that you know the more
kids the merrier and it's like more
people to love
[Music]